what's going on guys this is rob and in
response to the last video that we made
about like wanda actually being a mutant
that there are a lot more mutants than
wanda mutants had actually been around
for a while before wanda that this guy
omar in the comments asked a question
which is a really really really great
question in relation to this here's what
omar asked but why would that be a mic
drop moment why should dr strange care
that wanda is a mutant he's never heard
the term and never met one so it's not
like dropping that knowledge on him
would be some huge moment maybe for us
but not strange seems like it has to be
something else that could be part of it
but it's definitely not the biggest part
of the reveal
so here's the significance of that right
i mean one to answer that first part of
the question on its face no doctor
strange or the idea of mutants it
wouldn't really mean a whole lot to him
but we'd also have to assume he'd be
given some kind of explanation about
what mutants are at very least some kind
of simple and basic explanation uh it
wouldn't be one of those things where
xavier is like hey man there's mutants
in your universe i mean it wouldn't
really tell them anything right like
right i mean you know it's like telling
somebody there's there's asteroids in
space okay cool i mean i guess whatever
but like why does that matter to me that
discussion completely changes when it's
like one of them is heading here like
that's that's when that conversation
shifts and it's like okay now that's
important right so if this basic
explanation that's given to dr strange
is mutants exist in your universe and
what we're talking about here is just
rampant power development with no
particular range no defined limit then
that shifts everything up and the reason
why is because if you look at the marvel
cinematic universe people only ever gain
powers under one of like three
circumstances right either they gain
powers through some kind of science
based event right science going wrong or
something like that or some kind of
science experiment so peter parker being
bitten by a radioactive spider bruce
banner being exposed to gamma radiation
steve rogers getting the super soldiers
here it's some kind of technological
cause so i don't know if you really
consider it powers but tony stark
becoming iron man carol danvers being
blasted by a cruise ship engine that
sort of thing and then you go into
people learning their power so doctor
strange agatha harkness so on and so
forth with mutations it doesn't work
that way right you're talking about
people just being born with powers and
there is no upper limit here it's not as
though when a mutant is born the most
powerful they could be is someone who's
like as strong as the incredible hulk or
they're all basically comparable to
captain america where they can run fast
and like they can punch hard no no
there's no limit there so a person could
be born with the power of just enhanced
strength where they are comparable to
steve rogers or a person could be born
with the power to alter reality on a
universal scale right and it doesn't
even have to be like some ultra powerful
mutant that can wreak havoc right
there's two examples of this so let's
take for example somebody like vanessa
carlisle so some of you guys may recall
that name that was the girlfriend of
ryan reynolds in the deadpool movie she
is a character called copycat in marvel
comics she's basically just like
mystique but what differentiates vanessa
carlisle from mystique is that mystique
can assume the form of a person vanessa
carlyle can assume their form and copy
their powers so let's say that it's
someone like jamie madrox the multiple
man the guy that can basically duplicate
himself now let's say that for whatever
reason vanessa carlisle has her sights
set on just destroying the world she
could just say okay cool i'm going to
copy the powers of jamie madrox and then
i'm going to tell my duplicates copy the
forms of the wives of the joint chiefs
of staff then kill the joint chiefs then
replace the joint chiefs i will take out
the president and then i will copy the
president and then we'll nuke russia and
russia will respond in kind and because
of entangling alliances now you've got a
global nuclear war just like that now
another really good example of this is
that in daniel way's wolverine origins
comic there was a point where wolverine
after the events of house of m had
basically relearned or at least
rediscovered all of his old memories he
remembered everything there's a point
where he breaks into the white house
really like sneaks into the white house
interrogates a high-ranking member of
the white house staff and then leaves
and by the time anybody even learned
that he was there outside of that person
he interrogated he was already gone at
any point he could have taken out the
president the idea of what we saw in the
old x-men movies right x-men 2 where
nightcrawler was like teleporting
throughout the white house i mean that
was overblown and overdrawn and it was
for the sake of like drama and like oh
you know oohs and oz and all that kind
of stuff nightcrawler could teleport in
and teleport out and the president would
be gone like that it could happen in the
span of like two seconds right teleport
in and then just like teleport the
president 30 000 feet in the air drop
him and then just teleport to a place
and like that's the end of it right the
president's gone just fell 30 000 feet
to his death out in the middle of
nowhere or maybe teleport him to the
middle of the ocean and drop him into
the america to the mariana trench and
then teleport out there's any number of
ways those kinds of things can happen
and those are just mutants who are by
all standards of measurement beta level
mutants maybe alpha level mutants and
like that's it they're not really
mutants who are like overly powerful
let's use someone who is right let's say
for example that there is some guy in
his 40s and we're going to change his
origin a little bit for the sake of this
particular you know and him being rolled
over into the mcu but let's say for
example there's a guy in his 40s right
and this guy for whatever reason his
powers basically manifested late some
moment of duress or because of the fact
that whatever the case is they just
didn't pop up during puberty the results
of this is that they just started
popping up and the guy doesn't know how
to control his powers he's a walking
talking just path of destruction when
his powers first manifest he can't
control them and ends up destroying his
entire city block and so in response the
authorities arrive the authorities send
him into a higher state of panic and he
starts letting off even more energy
destroying even more things now
eventually maybe shield gets involved or
something like that they manage to
successfully launch a strike on this guy
they kill him but because he's so
powerful he resurrects himself from the
dead that was matthew malloy in marvel
comics we've got a video on it right
we've got a video running over just how
powerful this guy was the only way they
could defeat him was to go back in time
and keep him from being born it was the
only way to destroy this guy because how
else can you kill a guy who can
resurrect himself from the dead and it
wasn't as though he wanted to it was
just he couldn't control his power so he
didn't know how to stop what it was that
he was doing because he was never
trained on how to use those abilities
the thing about having mutants in the
marvel cinematic universe is that it
basically shatters the rules that we've
been operating by in the mcu up to this
point we're no longer bound by like
technological advancement or or
scientific happenstance or just someone
being trained with regards to this
development of powers now we're at this
point where it's hundreds if not
hundreds of thousands potentially
millions of people who were born and
that on a tuesday it's a girl who's born
and her powers don't really manifest
until she's like 15 years old and when
they do she basically has the ability to
read people's minds right and to move
stuff with her mind right basically jean
grey but then let's say there's a guy
born on a thursday and the nature of his
power is to just let off explosive
energy and his powers manifest when he's
five years old because he's in a grocery
store with his mom and he wants to look
at some can of tomatoes and his mom
won't let him he throws a tantrum and
because he can let off all this energy
he wipes out three city blocks by just
exploding by detonating that's the kind
of thing you're running into that's the
potential that you have here basically
losing control of the circumstance under
which people's powers develop and how to
manage that that's why in the comics the
federal government launched project wide
awake contain and control the mutant
threat because now it's not one of those
things where like peter's bitten by a
radioactive spider his powers are
manageable it's just a few instances
here and there of people gaining
abilities now it's anyone at any point
in time can suddenly develop powers and
they could be a person that's a credible
threat to all of existence or they could
simply just destroy the world by
thinking about it not only that that's
in the the moment right now assuming
that doctor strange 2 doesn't wipe out
the entirety of the multiverse at the
end of the film which i still think they
are i still think they're going to
consolidate the entirety of the
multiverse down into like a singular
universe and basically go forward from
there but the whole idea the whole plot
of dr strange will basically allow them
to grab like the fantastic four and the
x-man and deadpool and all those
different properties and bring them into
the mcu itself but assuming that doesn't
happen and you have all these alternate
realities now you've got mutants in
alternate universes and while that may
not seem like it matters because there's
stories that we may never see or hear
from i would counter that with clyde
winchum clyde winchim was a guy who
lived in what was supposed to be the
real world in marvel comics but
basically he had the power to alter
reality he basically resurrected his dad
from the dead which freaked his mom out
so she cracked him over the head with a
candlestick and basically left him in
what was almost like a catatonic state
like a vegetative state the only thing
that ever made him happy was reading his
comics when the nurses at the at the
home took those away from him he
basically used his powers to alter
reality to bring all the superheroes and
supervillains from the from like the
marvel comics universe into his world he
snatched them out of their universe and
brought them into his own and we're not
talking about like just captain america
or anything like that we're talking
about all kinds of people doctor doom so
on and so forth all the way up to like
galactus right it was nuts now
eventually a different alternate reality
version of himself ended up becoming the
marquee of death a guy who was so
powerful he was wiping out universes
with a wave of his hand now do i think
the marvel cinematic universe will go
that far off the rails no but the point
that i'm making here and the reason why
it would matter to doctor strange is
that at this moment right now at least
as far as we're aware before we go into
doctor strange two the two most credible
threats stephen strange has to contend
with is wanda and like dormammu right
dorama who's basically locked away in
his own dark dimension and there's no
indication that he's managed to find a
way to escape from it we don't really
even know how how far down the rabbit
hole we're going with wanda how
villainous she may be or even on what
level her power exists she seems to
exist in terms of being able to alter
reality on a universal scale but all
we've seen her do is manipulate the town
of west view so we don't know how
expansive her abilities are we know
she's destined to be more powerful than
the sorcerer supreme but is she going to
die before she ever reaches that point
we don't really know but those are like
two people right imagine if doctor
strange had to concern himself with 500
000 people who had a wider range of
different abilities going from being
able to read and manipulate the minds of
everybody on earth to being equal to the
infinity gauntlet in just sheer raw
power and reality manipulation abilities
that's why it would matter to dr strange
because just the level of threats would
increase exponentially and it would
basically happen overnight depending on
how they decide to introduce them and
what dr strange intends to do about them
so with that being said guys we're going
to bring this video to an end hopefully
that answered your question
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace